All right. Let's walk faster. I only have 30 minutes.
I'm gonna take the elevator cars just to show you extra amenities. Yeah.
So this is my, my elevator, my personal elevator and the cloud house.
Oh, well come to mosque, crib, our crowd there's people, artichoke lamps. But,
um, so this is the gym. So as you can see, if you go in to see us,
this is what you can get. I do. I know right next door. Yeah.
It's incredibly loud. So I'm going to go here. This,
this might sound a little bit racist, but because you guys are Korean,
you guys probably do some K-pop dance. Like this mirror is really cool.
RP can do. You're like, uh,
It is my personal gym.
I don't know why there are people in some of my gym should kick them out soon.
We have a lot of artwork, so that's really nice, too beautiful.
And this time we're going to take the stairs for exercise. Ooh.
Spiral staircase. Yeah. But no,
you got to prioritize sometimes.
Yeah. Let's go somewhere else.
The cool thing about this place is you could also rent these bikes. Oh wow.
And you can pretty much go anywhere,
but you just have to bring them back and it's free. Yeah. Before we continue,
I just want to say that this video is sponsored by Skillshare.
Now they have a great promo going on.
If you sign up using the link on the description,
because they will give you two months of premium for free Skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands of classes,
covering dozens of creative and entrepreneurial skills,
explore classes in everything from film and video,
freelance and entrepreneurship, web development,
and more premium membership gives you unlimited access to high quality
classes from experts,
working in their fields to help you gain new skills and live your best life.
Skillshare is super affordable with an annual subscription of less than $10.
So I took a couple of classes and I was pleasantly surprised by one of her
classes. The class is called presentation essentials.
How to share ideas that inspire action by Simon Sineck
in case you don't know Simon Sinek, he is an author and a motivational speaker.
The first time I heard about him is from a viral video where he talks about
millennials in the workplace. I thought he was a great storyteller.
And for me, I think storytelling is an extremely important skill to have.
This class is short sweet and to the point,
and I highly recommend checking it out. Anyways,
the first 500 people to click on the link in the description will get two months
of premium membership for free. And then you can take any classes you want.
So check it out. Oh, and then the next thing we're going to see is this, uh,
Harbor market. And there's a vending machine where you can order food.
Ooh, it's pretty funny. Cause um, sometimes it screws up,
like if you buy the Vietnamese sandwich.
So do you want to.
You want to learn how to make more money with your YouTube channel? Yes.
Or do you want to learn how to grow your channel? Cause uh, no.
I'm your guy for that by your guy. I mean the guy who is like losing viewers,
every there, have you watched the startup series? I have each episode.
I think all of them. Probably all of them. Yeah.
I like DMD you back in the day and I didn't get a response. Oh yeah.
I remember that. I was like, you're kid. And then when you got back on my,
I think I need him now. I was like, wait, so you watch a start-up series back.
Dan also. Yeah. I watched it when you were how'd you discover on the rise?
I don't know. I think I'm not entirely sure because Oh wait. Oh no, no,
I didn't watch it as you were posting. I don't think. Yeah.
I think it was right after you finished a sort of series. And then I was,
I went back and watched all series, like why? Because you're trying to tack,
so I don't get whitewashed. Oh,
it's the start of series or just in general or serve series is just
entertaining. There are so many people that still think it's real. Yeah.
They're like, why don't
you just continue or not vine start-up and like,
why do you have to get new Charlotte's Oh my God. Yeah.
I'm like interested in tech a little bit. Hmm. Yeah, no,
I was a freshman in college, like exploring. Have you ever taken a CS class? Um,
in high school? Yeah. In high school. And how was that? It was okay.
I didn't really have like, what did they teach you? They taught us Java.
I've um, tried to,
I I've tried as in like spent one month or like a few weeks or
namely swerved or like Python.
Yeah. So the great benefit of computers is that
for years you got a really, really easy, Oh my God,
my microphone just shooting filmmaker. So as I was saying.
Yeah, with the
[inaudible] microphone as a CS major, you know,
you can come out with software engineering degree,
making like 150 to 200 K right off college, and then you can afford this place.
So think twice before you start your business major and you two argue.
This video is extra mental. Yeah.
What's what takes the most time when you fake videos and stuff like that.
For me, it used to be planning. Cause I used to script my videos,
but not anymore. Not anymore at all. It's completely edited.
Yeah. I'm selling out. So I just, I just close ads,
every single video and that it's not bad.
W what's the best case scenario for your YouTube channel?
Would you like to change a content direction? I love to do,
like, I love to do more creative stuff with videography. One day.
He's just like pretty much just like, you know,
like travel videos except for my daily life or yes,
with a cinematography, with a narrative.
I think a lot of travel videos are all effects and not enough narrative.
Oh, okay. Stripes. Oh, you're lucky. Again.
Those are both unintentional shots.
Okay. We'll leave after I get one.
It might be here. Might be here a while.
Nice. You're actually really good. I can tell.
Cool. Yes. Jump shot. Jump shot.
It is getting try not to hit the camera. Oh. I'm a professional.
Oh, all right. Let's let's switch.
I don't want to talk to you.
Oh, this is, this is RP now. And I'm going to show him a Toro. I didn't know.
You guys would dress up. I'm literally my pajamas, but it's fine, dude. Yeah.
I actually dressed up for this. Well, he's not dressed up. He always wears this.
It looks good though. Like it's yeah. It's okay.
It's it's it's her brand, I guess.
So it's from a brand anyways. So this is the living room, you know,
I bought a new projector. It's probably gonna take a while to turn on.
So I'm not gonna turn on, but anyways, you can come here and film this.
What do you know what this is? Is it a wireless phone charger?
It's a very expensive a coaster, but yeah. Boom. Wow.
Yeah. I always wonder what would happen if I, uh,
if I charged my phone gonna blow up
or maybe it goes to a hundred percent faster, why need a projector so big?
I didn't know it was going to be that big.
I thought it was going to be this size, but uh, yeah,
so I bought like the most expensive one and I work in tech. Okay.
Okay. And because I work in tech, I'm able to afford this. Oh. Yes. SNES.
That's cute. So, but yeah, for real, if you didn't enjoy
CS for your first class, it doesn't matter.
Because if you grind for a little bit, know your separate life. Okay.
I don't know if money is important to you, but for me it's important to feel,
you know, free. So you can buy a biggest projector. I'm just like,
it's financial freedom. Like you're like, Oh man,
Palo Alto restaurants are so expensive. Yeah.
I don't even think about the bill and I just, I just eat whatever I want.
Y'all look at this sick video. Oh, who's this thing.
Utuber I don't know if he looks trash. Wait, how do I go to bed?
I hate watching myself on YouTube, man. Oh man. Okay. Wait.
Let's watch your channel. Wait.
[inaudible] okay. Your channel is kind of hard to find Elliot choy. Okay.
There we go. Elliot toy Elliott, choy,
Elliot, Harvard, all man. Look at these thumbnails, man.
They're still high quality. So did you know that if you, um,
if you made a Harvard video,
it would blow up even though you don't go to Harvard. Yeah.
Makes sense. Are there any YouTube ads? You guys don't like? I mean,
just like in general. Yeah. Um, I might make a business.
One guy who lives in like mountain view. Yeah.
Just kind of an arrogant, rich prick. That's the guy. That's the guy.
That's crazy. You asked me this is not relative. You know, a city,
a dog save different, dude. Why do you always wear Adidas?
I'm talking to other so comfortable. Do you actually have any other? No,
I just have, but they're pretty thrilled. I, you should have some oil.
Let me show you my Adidas pants. Okay. So I bought these first for myself.
And then when I watched a 1 million studio, they all had it. Wow.
So they copied me, man. Yeah. Clearly. Holy. Anyways. All right,
let's go back and pretend you didn't see my man. All right.
Let me show you my dope pass-through and where you can get,
if you have a sick salary. Okay. All right. First,
you got my sick house. Oh, why do don't even need it?
That's just like excessive at that point. Yeah.
I think for pornography is really good. Okay.
They don't even make that aspect ratio in pornography. I know, but,
but it's not about watching one video for me. At least I have to click on one.
Yeah. Oh, okay. Got it. Once the task. Right? Right.
So what I do is I have like, yeah, yeah.
And then another cool thing that you can do is it can act as
two different monitors. And this is actually impressive.
For example, now this monitor is attached to my computer.
Wow. This one is attached to so crazy.
What if you had two monitors? What if had
it's double the price. Why would I pay twice for a monitor? Yeah.
But then again, it's like, this is like 1600 trouble. Right. But yeah. Why,
why shouldn't I have two monitors? Wait, there should be a good reason for it.
Oh yeah. What if I do want something in between? Whatever. I'm just rich, bro.
Okay. Yeah. Here, here.
You know where I could wirelessly charge my phone? Where's my phone. Okay.
Let's pretend this is my phone.
So it's a slightly better because back then I would have to plug my phone in.
Right. And when I wake up, I'd have to detach it,
which requires an extra step. But now when I wake up,
I'm just like this that's that's crazy deep. Boom. Yeah.
And also I wanted to try, I was really hoping for this one thing,
I'll tell you what it is.
I was hoping that this would work because this is like a wireless charging.
Also it's doing something. Yeah. It's freaking out. Look
what you're supposed to do. This is actually kind of annoying.
You're supposed to charge him like this and then there's wireless charging.
So I thought it would be the same kind of word short and cut. It's not. Okay.
So I should DCS to get, to get wireless charging everywhere,
more efficient to marginally. Oh,
I didn't even see that. Oh, wait a second.
And now you got me interested. Like it spits out less. If you're closer to the,
uh, to the head, let's see. Oh my God. Like it was like,
and it's like, all right. Also Sensodyne.
It's the most expensive, uh, basic in gap.
So I'm pretty rich. And then syrup.
You use that too, right? I do. Yeah. Good. What else do I have?
That's impressive here with like K-pop videos.
I used to have an iPad here and I would watch K-pop while I brush my teeth as
well.
But I've outgrown that now you'd have like a TV inside of your mirrors thing.
Yeah. That'd be sick, but no, I don't. Oh my God. Elliot twice. Still sick.
I like this YouTuber. Yeah. I know. I don't know about that goddess. Yeah. Nice.
Cause like I know Elliot likes gear and uh, yeah, here, I got microphone.
It's wanting to my blog.
Just like pull it here and I talk and then I put my camera here and then I
connect this to the camera so that I could see what I look like.
It's pretty cool. Right? What's your setup? Like? Uh, probably not as cool.
So it doesn't matter. It's my iPhone on the tripod. Most of the time.
I'll at least have an iPhone. That's not bad. Or your iPhone? Elliot sec. Okay.
And then, Oh yeah. AirPods. Do you guys have AirPods? No, I don't.
What did apparently it's for gen Z? Like this is like the rich show.
I guess I can't be in the upper-class you know?
I don't know like a bunch of dead, but yeah. I mean,
I bought it when it first came out. So part of the second one's coming as soon.
No, they're already out. You don't have them. I,
I thought you would have written. Yeah, I know.
I thought I thought you were in tech. Yeah, I know. I know. But okay.
Now I'm not going to buy them. I'm going to buy them. But yeah,
the second ones are pretty good, but mine are not. Yeah.
Apple watch. See, this is the one thing I never understood. What is it for?
Yeah, absolutely nothing.
It's actually just to tell people you're rich and right.
But mine is trashed because the red.is not there. Okay.
But people still know your. No. Oh, okay. Well we'll only if I hide,
if I hide it. Well, cause this is actually a generation three,
not generation four generation four is the latest version.
It's all going right over my head. I don't know.
And he's how much do you think these ducks costs? 12 bucks each.
I think it was like 30 bucks each.
Let me use my extremely cool monitor to check it out. But like why?
Why though? Cause I'm much man. 50 bucks, 35 bucks in.
I'm not sure this one. I think this one's a Kiwi.
If you just didn't buy all of these, how much Richard would,
I bet you'd be $150 with you.
You could probably save it for the next AirPods for AirPods. Okay. Okay. Right,
right. You're rich. I'm sorry. I could just take into my savings account. Okay.
Okay. What else? What else? Uh,
how much do you think these costs that looks like? So. You buy a Walmart.
That's actually free. It's actually pretty cheap. That's trash. But Dan,
this is actually legit. It's a real painter. Like if you look closely.
It's paint. You know what I mean? Like the strides and.
Why don't you put this in there.
To monitor? You can afford things to look at your Elliot. Oh,
he'll ele you like yours. RP went. Where's your.
Hey listen, man. I'll be uploaded.
This is fun. Oh wait, have you guys heard of these.
It's old school?
Yeah. The flops over whatever.
I waited eight hours just to buy these uses piece of. What did they do? Uh,
the blue glass. But no, no, no. It's like Snapchat.
And then basically what you can do is you can record like 10 seconds with it and
then send it as a snap. Pretty cool. Right? Yeah. Let me check it. Look at this.
I have a mouse and the track pad,
but why redundancy, if you, if you learned about CS,
you would know what redundancy is all about.
Imagine you have a hard job and you have all your files there.
What happens if your hard drives that you lose our files? Right?
So redundancy is about, uh, copying those files into different,
you know, different, hard drives. Right? So that if you lose one,
you're not gonna lose all of it. Right. So, uh, but, but why two for redundancy?
And like, imagine if like, I'm like, Oh man, my mouse doesn't work anymore.
And then if you bought an expensive mouse, shouldn't it work. But it's not,
it's not that expensive. I have a cheap mouse.
Not because I'm poor it's because I actually like cheap mouses.
See that's what poor people say.
Can you do this? What's your mouse. And we'll think we have,
we all have trackpads on the laptop. Yeah.
But what if I'm using my desktop set up?
I'm sure I can configure some sort of shortcut. Yeah. You could actually,
you can actually just press like this or something. Yeah.
Or something like that, but still okay. Right. And pressed and pressed.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's crazy, dude. I'm definitely gonna study CS. All right.
My job is done here and always, I'm gonna end the video. Thanks for watching.
He's gonna join CS. All right. Thanks for watching guys.
Check out.
Ella channel, check out RPC channel.
He needs it.
He doesn't even have a silver play button, but yeah, it's coming soon. I swear.
I didn't have, I didn't have as much fun.
In college because I was in CS. Now that it's off the record.